foreign
let's go to almir in Minneapolis
Minneapolis I always say that wrong
every time what's up
hey can you guys hear me okay absolutely
what's up man
credit cards I know you guys are
um
for credit cards and I understand you
speak a little more clearly for us elmir
talk into the microphone there can you
hear him
perfect yep
um so I know you guys are against credit
cards and I understand why but I simply
figured out a system but for me I have
all of our recurring bills that we have
to pay for every month whether it's Thai
the daycare electric gas on a credit
card which saves in a safe account and
then every month when my credit card
payment is due which I'd pay anyways I
pay it off every month and I would get
50 sometimes 100 100 in reward points
every month
is there a negative to that or the
positive I use that fifteen hundred
dollars to reinvest in some certain
ETFs or stocks on Robinhood
well I don't know what plan you've been
following but it's not the Ramsay plan
and that's fine it sounds like you're
you're doing great financially you're
out of debt completely you've got a
fully funded emergency fund
yeah I'm out of debt yeah I have 15
maybe between our household income put
away I'm on a 20-year loan for a 20-year
term for a mortgage
um so I'm doing all the steps I and I
know that's the one big step is no
credit cards but I just found that
something that worked I implemented a
few years and I'm Building Wealth out of
it sure well we would never tell you to
invest in single stocks and I did a
whole episode on the Robinhood app on my
podcast to find print so if you want to
learn more about that you can check that
out but the the credit card dilemma that
you're bringing up is one that we get a
lot and everyone that brings it up is
going listen I get it people can't
control their spending but I have
mastered it I have figured it out I
never spent a dime on interest I get my
cash back I am winning I'm beating the
system
and at the end of the day it's not
moments like that where you lose it's
the moments where life doesn't go
exactly according to plan and now all of
a sudden we have to put those
on the credit card because we had an
emergency that exceeded our income and
we don't know what to do now and life
kept punching Us in the face and we went
well at least we're still getting the
Cash Back Rewards and so truthfully I
think you can do a lot better just
spending with a debit card when you use
your own money and I understand you're
putting recurring bills that you
normally would spend on right
that's it but psychologically we make
different decisions number one with
other people's money and number two with
that kind of reward level thinking
and Amir I'm I'm was in your exact shoes
okay
I had recurring bills put on a credit
card that got me free flight points and
I never was going to be in debt again I
paid it off every month and all was good
let me tell you why I quit okay and I I
don't think any of the rules apply to me
and I always think I'm the exception
right
um so I'm like you never gonna have a
problem I've got an emergency fund I'm
not worried about ever going into debt
again I'm just I'm just going to take
their free money here's why I quit
I was beating that system if you will I
was playing their game and I was doing
fine
you are too
but somebody's paying that fifteen
hundred dollars a month that you take
home and you know who it is it's the
single mom with four kids that can't eat
and she's paying for your Robinhood
account
it was the guy who just got fired and
couldn't buy groceries and so he had to
put on a credit card that was the dude
who was paying for my flights at 30
percent
and I couldn't stomach taking a free
flight
off the backs of some of of people who
had hit rock bottom or people who had
legitimate issues psychologically with
controlling their spending or whatever
I didn't want I opted out of that system
because it's disgusting and I don't want
that free flight I'll pay for my own
flights I'll figure it out
does that make sense that makes sense
that's why I opted out of it man the
whole system is so predatory off those
who are struggling who don't know any
better or who are don't or found
themselves in a mess
where their rent just doubled and they
live in a city they can't afford and
they can't get a new job in one day
well I I've got you I got you covered at
30 at 28 and if you miss a payment it
goes to 40 and by the way you can never
borrow I'm I'm just out of that system
man because somebody else is paying for
my flights that's why I got out yeah I'm
I'm curious how mayor how much are you
spending a month to get 50 bucks back
so here's I have a two two-way system
one of my system so I started this a few
years ago and I I think the biggest
thing is discipline I'm a very
disciplined person I mean I'm an
immigrant as well I've seen my parents
in debt and I see what credit cards can
do I train myself to never be in debt
and I never will
um but I've like I said recurring bills
that get charged like my tide my daycare
all those things will get charged in my
account then I do the Dave Rams the
envelopes and then in one of my envelope
systems one that one the envelope says
return or credit card payment so we have
two credit cards one of the smaller one
so if we buy groceries I'll put
groceries on the credit card I'll
transfer money from that envelope to my
so I always it always balances you just
have to be different this is some fancy
footwork you're doing man and I my
parents are immigrants as well my dad is
from Egypt and I watched him do this
growing up and it's giving me PTSD to
hear about it because I know the anxiety
of oh my gosh we had to move the zero
percent APR to this card to get this
reward and it's Bonkers man so you do
you but man it's so much more peaceful
to do the Ramsay way yeah I'm opting out
of the system I'll I'll pay the the
peace tax is what I call it I'll lose
out on that 50 bucks to not have to deal
with it man
um but thank you so much for the call
almir